مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون
الدعم الاستراتيجي والسؤال المطروح الان
بعد ان تم القاء القبض على المشتبه به وهو
جاكتك سيرا
الضابطه في الحرس الوطني الجوي
ما هو حجم الضرر الذي يمكن ان يكون قد قام
به هذا الضابط للامن القومي الامريكي
من الصعب ان نجم لاننا لا نعرف ما هي
الوثائق التي وضعت على الانترنت يكفي
القول بان الوثائق التي اشير اليها في
التقارير الصحفيه هي مرعبه من وجهه نظر
امن قومي
هناك جهود متعلقه بالحرب في اوكرانيا
وعلاقات مع شركائنا وحلفائنا كل هذا قد
تضرر ولكن ما الذي يعنيه ان يقوم عسكري
بتسريب وثائق بهذه الدرجه من الحساسيه
والخطوره
الحاله كان هناك اعتقال وهذا هو طيار من
الحرس الجوي الوطني فيما سجوست هذا الرجل
عمره 21 عاما وهذا هو النوع الغباء
والحماقه التي تتوقع من شخص في هذا العمر
المشكله الحقيقيه هي انه عندما يكون هناك
سبيل لك للتصريح والصلاحيات ولم تقم بامور
كثيره في حياتك لذلك لا يتطلع الناس اليك
كثيرا لذلك انت تحاول ان تثبت نفسك في هذه
الحاله الكثيرون من الناس لديهم خبره
وقاموا بامور كثيره في حياتهم وكانت مفيده
الاشخاص في عمر 21 لم يفعلوا اشياء قيم في
حياته لذلك نحن نسلم لهم معلومات قيمه
وهذا هو الدرس الذي يجب ان نست من هذه
الحاله سيد جيمس فعلا هو الشاب هذا عمره
21 عاما ولكنه ضابط وهو عسكري
الولايات المتحده في الوقت نفسه لديها
علاقات عسكريه دفاعيه وقواعد في حوالي 76
دوله حول العالم كيف يمكن ان تحتوي الان
وزاره الدفاع والاداره الامريكيه
تداعيات بسبب تسريب مثل هذه الوثائق
[موسيقى]
ضابطا ولكنه كان مجندا فقط لنصحح بنسبه
لسؤالك الجواب هو ان الامراض صعب خلافا
لما نراه في الافلام حيث كل عملاء
الاستخبارات هم جواسيس ولكن الواقع هو ان
الحكومه
الامريكيه بارعه في الابقاي على الاسرار
ولكن لا شيء مثالي ولا شيء لا يمكن
اختراقه اذا فهذا يعتبر ليس القاعده ولكن
ما هو شاذ عن القاعده ولكن القضيه تتعلق
ربما خطط استراتيجيه لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه
وقد تكون لها علاقه ايضا بمعلومات سريه
وخطيره جدا فيما يتعلق بقواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه المنتشره حول العالم وبالتالي
كيف يمكن احتواء اثر هذه التسريبات
الجواب هو فرض
قيود امنيه على من له صلاحيات ومن يحصل
على تصاريح ولديه سبيل للوصول الى
الاجراءات الحكوميه السريه ليس هناك طريقه
مثاليه حقا لكي نضمن هذا الامر مئه بالمئه
ولكن كيف تفسر يعني ذلك للدول الحليفه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
نامل ان نفعل ذلك من خلال الدبلوماسيه
الناجحه
الرئيس بايدن قال بانه تم اطلاعه على هذه
القضيه يعني حاولت تقليل من من اهميتها
ولكن انت باعتبارك يعني كنت مساعده وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون الدعم
الاستراتيجي هل تعتقد بان هذه التسريبات
وهذه الوثائق لها خطوره استراتيجيه على
الامن الدفاعي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انا اعرف ما قراته في الصحف وما رايته في
الاعلام وللاجابه عن سؤالك رغم انني لم
اطلع على هذه الوثائق يمكنني القول ان
التقارير الصحفيه تشير الى ان الكثير من
المحتوى في هذه الوثائق هو ليس شيئا جديا
وخطيرا ما هو خطير حقا هو الاضرار التي
تلحق بنا بسبب هذا الامر مع حلفائنا
وشركائنا بالاضافه الى الافشاء المتعلق
بمعلومات استخباراتيه ولكن علينا ان نرى
الوثائق لكي نحكم بكل تاكيد وانا لم ارى
هذه الوثائق لذلك لا اتوقع ان اكون قادرا
على ان اجزم دون رؤيتي هذه الوثائق
والاطلاع عليها في مثل هذه الحالات من
سيوجه الاتهام هل ستوجهه وزاره العبد
الامريكيه ام وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
باعتباره يعني هو عضو وعسكري ضابط في
الحرس الوطني الجوي
ج جدا واعتقد ان هذا دور وزاره العدل
ستقوم بالتحقيق ايضا في هذا الصدد معهم